Hindi angkop ang quantum computer para sa lahat ng problema,
pero may ilang klase ng problema
at mga potensyal na use case kung saan inaasahan natin
na magkakaroon ng epekto ang quantum computing.
Kabilang dito ang simulation, tulad ng
pag-model ng mga proseso at sistema na nagaganap sa
kalikasan; paghahanap at optimization,
na kinabibilangan ng paghahanap ng pinakamahusay o
pinaka-optimal na solusyon sa isang sitwasyong may
maraming posibleng sagot; at matematika
at pagproseso ng data na may kumplikadong istruktura,
kabilang ang mga aplikasyon para sa machine learning.
Ang mga quantum algorithm ay gumagamit ng bagong paraan
para sa mga ganitong problema, gamit ang
natatanging mga katangian ng quantum physics tulad ng
superposition, interference, at entanglement.
Naiipit ang mga regular na computer
sa pag-explore ng ilang bahagi ng computational space,
kaya hindi nila mahanap ang mga pattern na ito.
Ang mga quantum computer ay nilagyan ng
dagdag na kakayahan o mas mataas na performance
para sa ilang problema dahil sa kanilang quantum na katangian.
Para lubos na maunawaan ang potensyal ng mga quantum computer,
kailangan ang malalim na pag-aaral ng computational complexity theory —
isang sangay ng computer science na nakatuon sa
pagsukat at paghahambing ng computational na pagsisikap na
kailangan para malutas ang iba't ibang uri ng problema.
Nagbibigay ito ng kapaki-pakinabang na balangkas
para ilarawan ang iba't ibang speed-up
at mga klase ng problema na narararanasan sa
computing.